nombreuses réactions au lendemain de
cette allocution du chef de l'état
notamment au sujet de l'extension du
pass sanitaires les français partagés
entre satisfaction d'un côté et
scepticisme de l'autre et j'ai supporté
vaccin mais c'est juste pour le principe
de la vaccination obligatoire
chacun a droit de faire ce qu'il veut
je suis absolument grandiose et ben oui
un effort à faire ta part de tout le
monde alors je sais qu'il ya des gens
qui sont pas contents de se dire qu'il
ya une obligation néanmoins je pense
quand on est en france on a de la chance
d'avoir aussi des vaccins alors que les
pays qui n'arrivent pas en avoir
aujourd'hui et je pense qu'on n'a pas
assez conscience parfois de la chance
qu'on a d'être en france est de pouvoir
être protégés sur nous pour notre santé
c'est quand même une crise de l'eau doit
on n'a pas le droit de voir circuler
librement
c'est une pour moi c'est inconcevable
toi je suis vraiment content
mais pour l'instant je sais de quoi je
suis pas vacciné donc je fais pas ça
très normal de rendre la vaccination
obligatoire ce que chacun devrait être
libre de choisir s'il veut se faire
vacciner ou pas après voilà c'est pas
obligatoire mais tout le monde va y être
contraints plus ou moins si on veut
retrouver une vie normale